[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les shadoks avait résolu leur problème
culturel grâce à l'ordinateur toubel
l'ordinateur était un animal raisonnable
composé d'une partie molle d'une partie
dure et qui vivait dans les champs tous
les matins il donnait ses 6 à 7 litres
de crème de connaissances c'était de la
connaissance d'art anti 0% de matière
culturelle et cérébrales évidemment
étant donné que les shadoks voulait pas
trop empressés de ce côté là
l'ordinateur chats blogs dans son
principe reposer sur deux bases logiques
la première lui servait à se reposer la
deuxième était hypothétique et lui
servait à faire des calculs
ces calculs étaient effectués selon la
méthode dite du calcul des prop david
ajouté quand on lui demande est une
addition de plus 2 par exemple il
répondait que plus de ses probables que
ça fasse quelque chose il y a une chance
sur deux que ça fasse 33 et une chance
sur but que ça fasse n'importe quoi
d'autre de zéro à l'infini contre si on
leur demandait de calculer une chance
sur but il répondait selon le même
principe que il ne s'en furent but on
avait une chance sur deux que ça fasse
une chance de prendre 3 et une chance
sur dur que ça fasse n'importe quoi on
appelait ça le principe d'incertitude
parce qu'il y avait une chose dont on
était sûr c'est que c'était faux
[Musique]
ou alors si c'était juste c'était
vraiment par hasard ou qu'il y avait une
erreur quelques bons coups il
fournissait aussi de la logique
informelle du genre tous les chats sont
mortelles socrates est mortel donc
socrate est un chat ça ne faisait pas
tellement aux shadoks socrates soit dit
en passant mais ça sortait de
l'ordinateur et c'est elle a hérité
d'ailleurs le shadow que n'avaient pas
intérêt à dire le contraire
qu'ordinateur s'est chargé certes pas si
l'on vit le chat d'obtenir ce n'est pas
deux fois et en plus ça lui apprenez la
politesse c'est ainsi que le chat d'oc
ordinateurs de poubelles qui n'était
devint le dépositaire des principes
shadoks les plus sacrées trompe de la
raison et du savoir de la sagesse et des
arts ménagers
[Musique]